oi pessoal tudo bem eu sabia que max tem
dez anos da cidade de maria em que eles
são paulo estou aqui em são paulo há
dois anos
hoje estou aqui para falar sobre o
excesso de lixo no mundo nos últimos
meses percebi que as pessoas só estão
falando sobre política é bom falar sobre
política mas tem muita gente culpa os
políticos por tudo eu sei que ele estava
em um monte de coisas erradas mas tem
hora que a gente tem que parar e
refletir
ele tem outros problemas que ele teve
mais de nós aqui da política com o
problema do lixo infelizmente os
políticos não investem o problema do
lixo porque eu não voto em ver ninguém
interessa então somos nós que temos que
agir aqui em são paulo
percebi que o lixo não escolhe lugar
está nas ruas escolas comunidades e até
em bairros nobres
fico muito triste quando pára pra pensar
que somos nós que damos ao mundo mas
praticamente ninguém assume que já deles
no chão e às suas escolas e até na praia
e pensam só um saquinho plástico só uma
caixa de suco o chiclete uma sacola
o só queria muito eu só entendo porque
as pessoas continuam fazendo isso ela é
tão fresca do nosso planeta onde todos
vivemos um dia minha professora cláudia
deu uma aula diferente ela falou sobre o
excesso de lixo além dela foi incrível
ela me incentivou muito mas muito legal
as professoras e professores saem sobre
esse assunto pois assim elas ajudam as
pessoas a se conscientizarem mais pois
com uma aula você pode conquistar mais
assim como eu o senti bem depois dela
dela tive muito mais crescimento e que
saber mais procure na internet para
saber onde ele ia parar e e onde as
pessoas jogavam o lixo vai parar em
aterros sanitários e lixões e apenas
três por cento do lixo é reciclado
as pessoas o jogo é de escolas nas ruas
e até na praia
como você já do lixo
quando você joga lixo na praia quando
todos rodovia lixo na praia quando a
maré sobe levemente até o mar
assim os animais aquáticos como em dois
com funding com seus alimentos podem até
morrer plantados e quando você joga lixo
na rua quando chove causa das enchentes
que tanto nos preocupam quando estão
usando nas ruas e tacho vendo agora você
percebeu que o lixo pode ser perigoso
as opções que temos são as áreas elas
precisam estar no conjunto do ar
reciclar que pensar política pública e
educar a sociedade
nós não podemos fugir não temos que
enfrentar
eu tenho um sonho que nosso mundo seja
sustentável para gerar boas
oportunidades para todos e que todas as
pessoas respeitem as outras têm nenhuma
diferença
eu vou terminar por aqui e espero que
vocês tenham gostado da apresentação
muito obrigada